the FBI and U.S Air Force aren't talking
about the reason two dozen agents
allegedly busted down the doors in a
pair of Nevada homes that was earlier
this month a
report on the search for
more properties owned by the owner of a
website that focuses just on area 51.
Nevada's top secret military base York
arnew gave his only on-camera interview
to Chief investigator George Knapp
the website dreamlandresort.com has a
new Rye addition to its content this
week endorsed by the FBI and U.S Air
Force a sarcastic reference to the
November 3rd events that upended the
life of the website's owner jorg arnu my
life has been very much turned upside
down by all this Arno has managed the
site since 1999. it's a central
Clearinghouse for anything and
everything related to the world's most
famous secret base there's absolutely
nothing that I would consider classified
or that I know to be classified on my
website it's pretty much the same stuff
that you find on other websites also and
I've repeatedly actually stated in my
discussion forum that if ever anyone has
a legitimate issue with what I'm posting
let me know and I will take it down two
teams of federal agents more than a
dozen in each group bashed in the doors
of two homes owned by arnu one in tiny
Rachel Nevada not far from the base and
one in Las Vegas They seized computers
phones files along with a wealth of
personal property but our news still has
no idea what they were after he says 40
or so pages of the search warrant are
sealed probably a justification for the
search but at this point I don't know
what it is Area 51 has become so well
known and draws so many curious people
to its boundaries that the public
sometimes forgets just how strenuously
the government defends its secrecy
I found 31 or 32 of them so far in the
early 2000s a friend of our news fellow
Area 51 Watchdog Chuck Clark took us on
a tour of public lands surrounding the
base to reveal a network of motion
sensors hidden in the dirt to warn the
base when anyone approached days after
our news report aired Clark's Rachel
home was raided by The Joint terrorism
task force his computers and cameras
were seized Clark moved out of the state
and left Area 51 behind and more
recently when a Facebook prank Drew
thousands of UFO curious to the desert
to supposedly storm Area 51 the base
beefed up its already strong internal
security but also amassed an
overwhelming show of law enforcement
might outside the base to discourage any
Knuckleheads from crossing the line the
excessive secrecy surrounding 51 has
likely fanned the Flames of public and
media curiosity which is one reason our
news website exists at all what's the
big secret the public wonders Arno says
his attorney told him he will likely
never get his computers and cameras
returned even though it's unlikely he
will ever be charged with the crime he
thinks this was entirely about sending a
strong a vague message at this point I
don't know exactly what I'm up against
but my best guess is that because my
residence is close to Area 51 and my
website Dreamland Resort is kind of
prominent in the field that I'm being
used to send a message to the area 51
community and my concern is how far will
that go sending that message George
Knapp 8 News Now